now polynomials does get pretty heavy
okay we start talking about multiplicity
of roots and particularly now that you
know about complex stuff and all that
but i need to take a few steps back and
i'm sort of not entirely sure where
everyone is at on this so even if you've
seen this before it's good to revise
because sort of like you know building a
structure your foundations need to be
really really first okay
so we're thinking about division
we are going to move on to polynomial
division but where i want to start
is just with numbers okay because we
understand numbers a lot better
so for instance
come in
hello you looking for something
yeah is there anything in there
someone give me a two-digit number
someone give me a four digit number
six thousand what
two hundred and sixty dollars
all right now
we can do this let's give it a go okay
14 to six how many times
none 14 into 62 how many times
eight how many times
still four
still
gives you 56 again which gives you
12
3 how many times
so that gives us
11.
goes in no time so that's what i've got
okay
by the way for bonus points there are
three numbers here right the 14 the 628
48 they all have names
which ones which
we know what the three names are right
there's the
the divisor
there's the
dividend and
the question okay now the easy way to
remember this
is that if you just write this out
they're in alphabetical order okay so
you've got
what we did was 6283
divided by 14 which is 448 with the
remainder
right
so you've got in order dividend divisor
quotient just can read it that way
all right now
we've just gone and worked out the
quotient but i want to write from this
what we call the division transformation
on the basis of this okay
what this is saying is i can rephrase
6283
as
the divisor and the quotient
together plus the remainder yes so i
should say 14 times
448
plus the remainder okay cool good this
is fine
now let's shift gears okay let's go into
polynomial division okay i'll get rid of
this guy you don't need the working
anymore i just want this result okay
okay let's um
let's take similar kinds of numbers
let's go i'll make this
i'll make that two let's take these guys
let's just make it a negative three for
the sake of it
all right what do i do
you say how many times does x go into 6x
cubed and the answer is
6x squared times whatever x may be now
what
multiply by which gives me 6x cubed
minus 2x squared sorry 12x squared what
do i do with that
i subtract which gives me 14.
bring down the eight
okay now what
14x multiply back
14x squared minus 28x
which gives me
36.
subtract 3.
how many times
36
multiply back
36 x
minus 72
i promise i didn't do that on purpose
seriously that's
really creepy
okay you know have you heard like those
you know there's mathematical acts where
they're like oh do all these things and
suddenly you get some magic i'm ready at
all that's not what i intend
all right we did a division
transformation
for numbers so how can i do this
for the polynomial what am i going to
write
this is the original now this is the
dividend the dividend here is
six x cubed plus two x squared plus
eight x minus three
okay so what's that equal to
x minus two times
koi [ __ ]
okay yeah
plus the remainder
okay
gotta play that kind of thing okay all
right so there you go right now this
division transformation is very
important it's vitally important
for the remainder theorem and the factor
theorem okay but just before i do show
you the remainder and the factor theorem
right
number one hands up if you reckon you
could quote for me the remainder in the
factor here
anyway
okay let's let's let's pull the bar a
little lower who thinks they know what
the remainder in the factory throughout
even though they can't explain to anyone
like i think i might recommend
yeah okay all right heads up
we will get to that but before i do that
i need to get you all the same page in
terms of never ever having to do this
polynomial long division anymore at
least
if we have a monoclinia factor okay
sorry i should say monique linear
divisor because that's what you're
usually going to get okay so maybe you
want to make a little subheading
which is synthetic division
synthetic division now i know some of
you know how to do this
because i've seen the working out on
your pages from when i gave you that
test the other week okay but i know not
all of you have seen it before so i'm
going to show it to you
please note
see their division is primarily for
monic
linear
divisors
it doesn't only work with that but
the advantages you see with synthetic
division is that it is faster and
simpler but the versions of synthetic
that work for other kinds of devices you
start to lose some of that speed and
simplicity okay so instead we're just
going to remember we're going to learn
the method for this because that tends
to be the most useful thing okay as
you'll see shortly
so here's what i'm going to do
do you notice
as we go down this long division okay
the x's the x terms
in some sense they don't matter right
because they follow a very predictable
path no matter what the coefficients are
you're always going to get your x cubed
here your x squared here your x's here
your constants here every single time
without fail that is if you do your
division properly right
what's really important is the
coefficients you get out of that process
okay so the first thing we're going to
do to save time
is all we're going to write for the um
dividend is its coefficients okay so
let's write the coefficients you're
going to get 6
2
8
negative 3.
okay
now
to help distinguish between this and
lower division instead of doing the long
division sign we do
the synthetic division sign which is
exactly the same but upside down
okay
radical i don't
know what we're going to put over here
instead of this as the divisor
i'm going to put
the zero that corresponds to it now this
is x minus two
so the zero or the root that you would
get out of having a factor of x minus
two
is just two
that's the number
okay
draw one more line
right
now remember i told you that we're going
to only be considering monic linear
factors okay so if it's only monic
you know exactly what this number is
going to be
without having to do any calculations
because you're always going to be
dividing by one right so you're always
just simply going to get this number
straight back does that make sense the
leading coefficient
of the dividend
will be the leading coefficient of the
quotient every time if you're dividing
by something modic so here's my first
step
all i have to do
is write down the number six that's all
okay now apart from that step i'm now
going to do the step which iterates it
goes over and over and over again
watch carefully follow with me okay
6 times 2 is 12.
i multiplied
now i add 2 plus 12 is 14.
multiply again 14 times 2 is 28 now i
add which gives me 36.
36 times 2 is 72 i multiply it now i add
there's 69
okay
now just stay with me
what was the degree
of the dividend
the degree of the dividend was degree
three
now remember i'm dividing by a linear
divisor so what would you expect the
degree to be afterwards
two
okay so remember we said the x's don't
really matter i can fill them in after
watch
it's going to be two and then one and
then a constant and then a remainder
okay
was that faster better believe it was
faster right not only is it faster
it's actually once you get used to it
that is it's less error-prone because as
i go down
notice what i chose was the zero which
is the opposite of this number okay so
that's why here we were subtracting but
here i was not subtracting
i was adding
now addition subtraction are the same
thing but believe it or not most
people's brains are better and faster
at addition even when they're exactly
the same numbers okay
you're avoiding things like this where
there are double negatives if that makes
sense okay
it's absolutely accepted absolutely
provided you said it out probably okay
all right now that's the way synthetic
division works do you want me to do
another example you're pretty content
with that
is that yes another example or yes i'm
content
you guys have no help at all
another example shall we okay all right
let's do some new numbers um
x to the
fourth
now the great thing about synthetic
is that
the longer the question in the division
the more gains you get so we're going to
divide 2x to the 4 minus x squared plus
5x minus 3
we're going to divide by x plus 3. okay
so
what's the first thing that i do
it's the coefficients the coefficients
are what matter okay so i go 2 and then
immediately i notice
there's no x cubed term
so another way of saying that is there
are zero x cube terms
so i write the zero now the rest of it
proceeds minus one
five
negative three okay
what will be the number i put here
it's the zero that corresponds to this
to me negative three
okay
you ready
the very first step the one that doesn't
repeat
is you just take the leading coefficient
you write it down okay from there
i'm going to multiply add multiply add
multiply okay watch multiply first time
gives me negative 6. now i add it
okay
multiply gives me 18. now i add
multiply gives me negative 51.
now i
uh sorry
is that right yes
multiply this is the worst number i've
chosen uh negative there is 46 what's
that 120 plus 18 138 yeah
plus
now i add them which is 135
i guess
okay we started with degree four so i
ought to end up with degree three two x
cubed minus six x squared plus seventeen
x minus forty six remainder 135 now if
you would you're more than welcome to
test that out by long division
i'm going to go get on with other things
but i've confidence that that's right
okay we're doing exactly the same
computations just in a
more efficient way really okay
now i said before
that the
way we learnt it only wasn't wanting
many devices but i said that's kind of
okay
why
why are monic linear devices the ones
you're going to be using over and over
again
why x plus threes and x minus twos why
are they the ones that come up
repeatedly
okay so it comes from the factor theorem
okay so i want us to look at this um
division transformation here
okay
and
i want us to think about it in general
terms
so
okay so now
you can call this the remains
okay have a look at this thing here
right
we start with some polynomial i'll call
it p
okay
and what we're saying is
i can phrase it in this particular way
if i divide by something okay so what
we're dividing by i'm just going to
think about monique linear
divisors okay so generally speaking
they're of the form x minus a and of
course a can be negative if we want to
get x plus threes and so on okay
now
this other piece here that was the
result we got at the end that was the
quotient right so being that it's the
quotient i'm going to call it q
of x and i don't know what it is because
i don't know what p is
then you get some remainder at the end
invariably right unless it exactly
divides your energy
now have a look at this with me
if i can state this which is kind of
like this but in a general form right
therefore
if i substitute in that zero that
corresponds to the divisor
like this
this is a zero that corresponds to a
divisor
this is a zero that corresponds to
divisor if i sum it in what happens
well
this guy here will be a minus a
this will be
q of a whatever that happens to be
and then you have a remainder right but
because i've chosen this specific value
because it's the zero that corresponds
to it right
it turns this into zero that's why we
call that a zero right so therefore
this is just going to be your remainder
right
this is the remainder theorem at least
in
algebra and equations how could i word
it
how could i word it
what does this result mean in relation
to this
okay
when i divide by when dividing
the original polynomial
right
by this
monique linear divisor we just concocted
okay
you can instantly without going through
any of this fluff right you can work out
this final number
the remainder
without going through any of the
division
at all
right all you have to do
is evaluate it at the zero that
corresponds to that
namely
now
should we test that how would i test it
we just did this division here right
okay
let's see how our brains are going
two times negative three to the four
minus
negative three squared plus five times
negative three minus
three negative three to the four
eighty-one double it 162.
yeah
minus nine
minus 15
minus three
that's minus
24 27
looks like it checks out to me
okay which we ought to expect it to
right algebraically it makes sense
okay
now the important version of the
remainder theorem that we want is called
what's the special case
the factor theorem
okay we just did the remaining theorem
what is the factor theorem now that i've
warned you up do you reckon you could
tell me
can we could we write something like
this
that would correspond to that specific
time when we actually get a factor
not just a divisor or a reader
okay
when now we want something to be zero
what do we want to be zero
number one the remainder which is which
is this guy p of n so when p of a
equals zero what does that tell us about
the original polynomial
x minus a the factor that corresponds to
this zero
sorry the divisor is a factor of your
original
okay
because you test this out you get a
remainder of zero sweet it actually
divides through
okay
so in practice what do you do
you get some rubbish polynomial like
this
okay
and you don't test zero why not why
don't you take zero
because there's a constant term so you
know it's not going to be a factor
they'd all have to have x's in the to be
divisible by x right
so you don't test x what do you sorry
you don't test 0 what do you test
you test
watch and then if that doesn't work and
you get a number you test negative one
and then you do two and negative two and
you keep going about up to three and
negative three
okay
and then in some at some point they will
get a phantom right they can proceed
just as we have here